why don't we go next to A Treatise from
Boston A Treatise from Boston welcome
back to the program how's it going
hey David good to talk to you again
likewise um I have a quick question I
remember a few months ago we briefly
talked about
um ranked Choice voting yes and I can
remember three four years ago it not
being a very well-known system but after
Alaska adopted it and it's at least
blamed on Sarah Palin losing I'm
wondering if do you think that with
things like that like it
being aiding in a Democrat winning or at
least you know blaming it uh with Sarah
Palin's loss and things like that do you
think that it'll kind of its progress in
being adopted Nationwide will be
stagnated uh just kind of by these
right-wing talking points of that it's
uh just a tool by the left to uh you
know cheerleading with the majority of
that sort of thing I don't think it will
help and it's sort of similar to
movements to move from an electoral
college system to a national popular
vote are limited by a number of
different factors but many Republicans
are aware that we're not for the
electoral vote if we had a national
popular vote there's a whole bunch of
their winners who would have actually
lost so it is without question that at
least the Republicans that pay attention
know that popular vote isn't great for
them the extent to which they know that
that uh transferable voter ranked Choice
voting is bad for them I I think it's
less clear but I do think that the Sarah
Palin situation in Alaska is a
cautionary tale you know the truth is in
the midst of all the insanity of the
last year it hasn't been a topic
anyone's been talking about too much so
it actually could be an opportunity to
make some progress on ranked Choice
voting uh for dedicated activists
yeah I would say like definitely now
well it's not as in the mainstream I I
think it kind of was within like the few
months before the midterms but after all
that it kind of got lost in the shuffle
I agree I do have one other quick that
thank you for that I do have one quick
follow-up question do you have a
favorite political movie
not really I mean I think uh as far as a
documentary I actually forget the name
of it but it's a documentary from when
Paul bagala and James Carville ran Bill
Clinton's campaign
uh what's it is it called the war room
now I don't remember it's a it's a good
documentary I don't really watch too
many political movies to be honest
uh yeah I mean this one in ten are of
quality uh but fair thank you so much
for taking my call all right A Treatise
from Boston great to hear from you again